and is now at UT Austin and he seems to
be one of the best paid scientists on
the planet that's going to get the
attention because if you google his name
the first suggestion that comes up is
Constantine chemical many salary okay so
there there must be something to his
talks so he's going to talk about PCA
thanks thanks Alex for that I'm just
under half of one percent of the UT
Austin's football coach's salary so as
soon as I get to one percent we'll have
a big party okay so I'm gonna tell you
about some work joint work with with
yanni Smith Yungas he was a who's a PhD
student at UT and also pratik Jane who's
that who's that who was it UT but he's
in he's in bangalore microsoft research
and i had the pleasure of visiting him
last year and this is a sort of the
product of a collaboration with with
these two since since then and it's a
it's a very simple problem so i'm going
to get i'm going to get right to it and
because it's so simple and the solution
is so simple i'm going to spend some
time before i get to the solution
telling you i am interested in the
problem and some interesting some
interesting facets of it so so here is
here is the problem so i'm thinking
about an extremely idealized version of
a co variance estimation problem so i'm
getting samples that are that come from
a gaussian and this Gaussian comes from
what's known as the spiked identity
family so basically as you can see the
covariance matrix is basically the
identity so there's a lot of noise
except there's there's this rank one
spike and it's that rank one spike
that's the that's the noise I'm sorry
that that's the signal so another way to
think about this is that you're getting
a you're getting a points that are
scaled along the direction V and then
you're adding you're adding noise to
them and so you want to find out what
that direction V
okay and and theta here is how much that
spike is scaled and you should think
about it as some small number certainly
nothing that scales with P ok something
like 2 or 5 or something and so the
algorithm of choice here would be to
just look at the SVD so you form a V
outer product of the wise you get the
empirical covariance matrix and we know
from from matrix concentration results
that by now are essentially standard
that the sample complexity that you need
in order to get a good estimate of V is
just the dimension so if you in this
kind of regime for this but this simple
model if you have if you have a about P
points or a multiple of P or something
like that you're you're going to get a
very good estimate of V so why is this
interesting I mean if you if you know
all of the matrix concentration results
and you've probably forgotten why I was
why I was ever interesting to look at
that problem it's interesting because
the noise really dominates each sample
so if you were to look at each why that
you get and look at its component and V
and look at its component perpendicular
to V the component perpendicular V is
way bigger it completely dominates the
component perpendicular to V will have
magnitude something like square root of
P whereas the component that scales with
v will be something more like like theta
and every single point that you get will
be very close to perpendicular to every
other point and very close to
perpendicular to the signal that you
actually want to recover okay so so this
is why people first started looking at
this problem and why it's maybe the sort
of classical problem of covariance
estimation in in the high dimensional
setting and again briefly the reason why
it works is because of matrix
concentration results so if you look at
so here notice so here I'm just looking
at the noise just the noise component so
I'm drawing w's from just the the
Gaussian with with with identity
covariance so there's no signal in there
and the point is that
the the spectrum of that concentrates
very sharply around around its
expectation and so in fact if you have n
samples and P dimensions then the
largest singular value of that empirical
noise matrix will be something like p
over n that's basically going to be the
noise square root of p p over n and so
as long as you take n the number of
points that's scaling with p then that p
over n is going to be something small
and therefore even if your spike is even
if your theta some small number it's
going to all of a sudden stick out but
if you have fewer than p points like
let's say square root of P points then
you have absolutely no hope by any
algorithm of finding the spike because
the largest because the spike is going
to be buried if you look at the if you
look at the spectrum of the matrix that
you're going to get all of the largest
singular values are going to come from
just arbitrary noise they're not going
to come from the signal you wish to
recover okay so this this is sort of
quite standard I'd say so what more do
we want since we have such a sharp
analysis of this in the literature so
let's go back to that simple algorithm
SVD what happens the input so the the
the vectors that you're seeing are each
order P every it's a every vectors in R
P but my algorithm requires me to look
to form this covariance matrix and
because I'm in the Gaussian setting I
didn't assume anything special the spike
isn't sparse the noise certainly isn't
sparse there's really nothing I can do
or nothing that i know of that if that
will help me form this covariance matrix
without without incurring this cost of
order P squared on the other hand the
output is also order p I just want say
the top principal component or the top
few principal components so I don't like
this picture because the input is order
P and the output is order P but because
of what I'm doing in the middle I have
to store p squared so that's what I
that's what I don't like so again the
memory complexity or storage here is is
order P squared instead of instead of
order P and what I'd really like is
do this with order P ideally I'd like to
do this with an algorithm that's not
just ordered p but just say stores one
vector or two vectors and K vectors if
I'm looking for the K principal
components but there's no real technical
differences so I'll just keep talking as
if it's if I just care for the top
principal component in this case of
course there is only one principal
component of interest V but you can
think of the generalization where the
spike is not a rank one matrix but a
rank 5 matrix or whatever so why is this
a why do I care about this problem well
I mean one one one trend is that we have
very inexpensive sensors that can
generate very high rate data so just
think about the phone that you have in
your pocket it can it can generate very
high rate data and actually Peter stone
and Kristen Graham and are leading a
project at UT where they've instrumented
a big part of the computer science
building with various sensors and and
robots and so it's there in the setting
where you might want to learn something
about images scenes or community
behavior basically when when the data
each data point really is going to be
extremely high dimensional so I want to
look at this P versus p squared thing
you know everyone talks about big data
analytics a less catchy title is small
platform analytics it's really big only
if it's big with respect to the
computing power that you have so if you
look online to see what your iPhone has
a typical iPhone may have about a half a
gig of ram but it only has 32 gigs of
storage my desktop in my office has 16
gigs of ram and a terabyte of storage
and you can buy a server with not
outrageous money that has something like
256 or maybe a half half a terabyte of
RAM but the amount of storage it has is
certainly not going to scale like P
squared so the point of this slide is
that vary across a range of different
computing platforms that we all have
access to you don't have P versus p
squared in terms of P so why is where am
I
because if my desktop is 16 gigs of ram
it means i can add two vectors that are
that are about a gig each so i can
manipulate things that are about a gig
but i certainly can't store one gig by
one gig matrix so that's orders of
magnitude beyond the storage that i have
and that's true for my iphone and that's
true for servers so so that's why p
versus p squared is not where we're
scaling in terms of what we can what
manipulations we can do versus what we
can store so after listening to several
talks yesterday I realized that there's
another natural motivation for for this
type of problem which is if you want to
solve a distributed PCA and we've heard
a lot about about sketching and so on
but but here's here's the problem
suppose that you want to solve this this
problem but your data are distributed on
many different servers and I'd like to
minimize the computation complexity so
this is sort of in line with santosh is
talk from from yesterday so just to make
just to put it in a specific setting
suppose that again i have p data points
so i know that if i had them all
together i know that i know that i can
solve the problem this sits in statistic
excuse me um statistically speaking the
signal is there and it's and it's
detectable so suppose that i have square
root of p servers and they each have
square root of p data points so what's
interesting here given the previous
discussion on concentration and and the
noise and the noise singular values is
that each one of these servers can't
compute anything about about v you only
have square root of p dimension i'm
sorry i square root of p data points but
you have but they're in p dimensions so
there's they can compute anything about
v now suppose nevertheless that i would
like to allow each server to send just
one vector so they're each server has
communication budget one vector is there
a way for these servers to compute to
compute via to compute V so again so the
reason individually no server can
compute anything
is that the singular value of the noise
in each serve the data that each server
has is is massive it's scales it scales
very rapidly with peak okay but of
course since we know that memory is
always going to be a bound on
communication complexity if we had an
algorithm that's order P then we know
that we would be able to have each
server sending one or two or a very few
number of vectors of length p and we'd
be able to do this okay so there's this
is sort of another way to to look at
this problem in the context of things
we've heard in the last few days okay so
that the techniques that we heard from
people like better assess and Ravi and
Mike and I guess Joel didn't talk
yesterday but I think I think maybe he
talked about it before I certainly
learned a lot of this from from from
Joel and reading his papers and and
david andrew also talked about sketching
but it wasn't exactly in this in this
type of context is that we we sketch we
form a sketch so this means you
subsample the rows or project the rows
or columns and in order to try to get a
simpler representation of your data more
efficient one and then you can work out
you can work there and indeed you could
do this so if I were to think about
stacking all the data points I get as
columns so the the sort of more or less
standard ways that you would sketch to
get something smaller is take take my
take Y which I've written as this as the
matrix of all my data points y 1 to y n
and multiply this the square matrix with
something that has that's very small in
one of the dimensions so let's say a
very tall and thin matrix and if these
are Gaussian or if it's a random plus 1
plus minus matrix then you know that
basically by or you hope that by kind of
the standard Johnson lindenstraße and
and so on techniques that you should get
something that is a good low-rank
approximation so if you take this matrix
Y times Q maybe that's something you can
store and you can put in storage and by
the way you can of course do this
multiplication without ever collecting
all the data so you you can form y
x q without ever using more than K times
P data so this is a sensible thing that
you could try to do but of course now
you can see from here this won't work if
if q zar say 01 vector so I'm selecting
outros or selecting out elements or
combining the roads these are just
Gaussian so if you add a bunch of
gaussians together you're not going to
get you're going to just lose
information it's just like subsampling
and if i were to subsample let's take
the simplest version of this where I
just sub sample some of my columns a lot
of the a lot of the results that that
betterish was talking about in the first
day was about subsampling and and
looking at the benefits of subsampling
for a general matrix but for this
problem that's just not going to work
subsampling is just like throwing away
data and it doesn't matter how you do it
so the thing is if you if you look in if
you look in those pew look in the
literature on sketching so if you if you
look at if you look at davids work from
a few from a year years ago a 2009 paper
by Clarkson and woodruff you'll find
upper and lower bounds the lower bounds
are computed using tools from
communication complexity that are nearly
matching but the point is that these are
all worst-case bounds and I'm not at all
looking for at a worst-case problem so
I'm what I'm trying to do for it for you
is sort of Mary my goals with the fact
that results from sketching would say
that you really can't improve on what on
what those what they say okay so I
mentioned this point that because the
data are Gaussian subsampling combining
projecting won't work at least I don't
know how to make it work and also if we
just look at the bounds that you get
from sketching they're more or less of
the flavor if you want to do a low-rank
approximation that the low-rank
approximation say y tilde that you get
you bound this in terms of the tail the
Frobenius norm of the tail of the best
low-rank approximation that's what I've
denoted by YK here but for us because
I'm looking at this model where that
we're looking at where
Michael variance is is is a rank one
perturbation of the identity I have this
long flat tail that tail isn't going
away so in other words that term on the
right is going to be order p in this
case so that's that's not that's not
good that doesn't that doesn't give me
what I want and in particular what we
want here is we're not doing co variance
estimation I want to estimate that spike
and so if if I get results of this form
that's not going to help me compute
compute that spike okay so this is all
to say that that that's sketching
results give you give you in some cases
tight bounds but there are tight in the
worst in the worst case and at least I
don't know how to use them in order to
in order to do what I want which is to
to get a good estimate of of V there are
some other approaches that some of you
may be familiar with we haven't talked
much about online learning but there are
there are approaches that are called
online learning but again the goal here
is more a regret minimization I don't
want to go into into that if it's not
something that you're familiar with the
point is that kind of the leading work
in an online PCA again has order a P
squared so here's a different idea what
is what is a singular value
decomposition solvent it's solving this
this problem which is a quadratic its
non convex but it's a quadratic
optimization problem so we might think
let's solve this by using a stochastic
gradient problem so if we if we look at
this if we look at the problem up top
you get an unbiased gradient if you just
sample one of the wise at random and use
that as your estimate of the of the
gradient and so first the plastic
optimization this is this is a very
classical technique frontsies and others
have have recently worked on on various
aspects of this particular form of
stochastic gradient ascent or descent
the problem here is that this is for
this problem is not convex so we can't
or at least again I don't know how to
use standard tools from the literature
now if you look back to old old results
on stochastic approximation robbins
monroe style results you'll it's quite
easy to check that asymptotic
convergence is guaranteed in other words
let me just parse this algorithm if you
don't what this is saying is that you
take your you can either see it as a
gradient as a stochastic gradient but
intuitively what this is doing is you
have your best guess at time T we had of
tea and then you see the next sample YT
and you move a little bit in that
direction that's all that this is saying
very simple it's a very simple algorithm
and we know that if you run this forever
and if and if your step size a to T
decreases at some rate like let's say 1
over T then this is guaranteed to
converge what I don't know how to do and
maybe some here someone here knows how
to do this is give a rate for this
problem so if this were a convex problem
then we have a very good understanding
of what rates of convergence are and how
long I'd have to run this but but I
don't know I don't know the answer for
this and I i I've actually it's not for
lack of trying so I'd really appreciate
if someone does know how to how to
analyze this in order to get to get a
rate but we do know that it'll that will
eventually converge there is some
related work that that Rob and Steve and
okay so Rob Rob Novak Laura balsano
who's now at Michigan and Ben rack did
the I think that was the first work they
called it grouse the GR is from grass
money and I don't remember what the
houses and then recently a Steve ride
with with Laura have done some follow-up
work where they do it they are able to
analyze a rate and what they show so
what is grouse grass is exactly like the
algorithm I showed you on the previous
page except it's just tailored to work
on rather than taking a step and then
projecting back down they actually work
on the grass mannion of low rank
subspaces so but but it's exactly the
same idea of taking a gradient step it's
just it's just adjusting that for for
the manifold so what they what recently
what what Steve and Laura were able to
show just in this last year is that is
that in the case where you start from
very close you have linear convergence
but it's also in the case where you have
no noise so the reason that their
problem is quite interesting and that
the result is interesting is that they
have they show that they show
convergence when you have lots of
erasers so in other words i'm giving you
in this example i'd be giving you just a
there will be no identity matrix you'd
be sampling just for exactly from the
subspace but I'd be making I'd be
erasing a lot of the coordinates and
then you get to see and then you're
trying to you're trying to converge onto
the subspace so again that this is work
that's in this direction but as far as i
know it's unable to handle noise and
also it's just it's a local result of
convergence I think it's a great step
but I I guess for the noisy case I'm not
sure how how to use that and I should
add that I've simulated it in North with
noise and it works great so so this is
this is an interesting aspect of of the
problem it's it's a here this is my
slide saying that I'm up but I find it a
little frustrating that it's been so
difficult to analyze because in fact you
can write a very simple it's
unfortunately nonlinear recursion for
the component for the component in the
right direction that you that you have
when you do this sort of simple update
the simple gradient gradient update but
even that seems a little bit difficult
to uh to analyze so here's a here's a
different idea for people that that
think about quadratic optimization you
know that of classical result from
control and optimization is that if you
have even a indefinite quadratic subject
to an indefinite quadratic constraint
like we have here so here we this is a
not a convex problem sort of the
as a result called the S procedure which
tells us that the standard stp
relaxation is actually exact so you
don't have to solve that non convex
problem you could solve a convex problem
which I've written here so this is now a
matrix problem similar to what Alex
similar in spirit to the relaxations
Alex was showing this morning and this
is just a linear objective with a trace
constraint and and some eigenvalue
constraints so you could think of doing
stochastic gradient ascent on this
problem and for that your apps you're
guaranteed by by what's now standard
theory in convex optimization that this
will converge and you get rates you get
rates of convergence the problem is that
this my optimization variable now is is
a P by P matrix and and you there's no
guarantee and in fact simulations show
that it's just not true that even though
the solution even though this will
converge to a low rank to a low rank
matrix rank one matrix intermediate Lee
this this great these gradient steps
will take you through a solution that
has an intermediate steps that have
arbitrarily high rank so so a natty sure
bro and and two of his students have
tried analyzing this and looking at it
when you force factorizations but again
that sort of destroys the empirically in
some cases it seems to work but but it
definitely but it destroys that the
convexity and therefore the convergence
guarantees that you have so the main
challenge in analyzing this stochastic
gradient at least for me was dealing
with the fact that you have a very large
amount of variance so here's an
extremely simple solution that that we
came up with with yan yason pratik it's
a very simple very simple algorithm and
basically it's just looking at a
streaming version of the power method so
suppose that you line up all your data
here and you you you break it up into
log P
blocks so why logp because we know that
power method traditional power method
takes takes log P iterations in order to
take salt converges converges linearly
and you can just pick you can just start
from any random v-0 and what the what
the what the power method would do it
was it would look at the empirical
covariance matrix saved from block one
and just keep multiplying v-0 by that by
that covariance matrix but we can't do
that because that would require forming
that covariance matrix so the
observation is that we can we can do it
once without storing the covariance
matrix or ever forming it that's sort of
the simple observation so if you look
here this would be the the teeth step of
the power iteration to go from V of T to
V of T plus 1 i'm multiplying it by the
empirical covariance from block t but if
we just rewrite this thing you can see
that you never have to form y y
transpose okay so you can do this by
just storing two vectors okay so that's
that's exactly what we are what we want
and so basically all this is is doing
power method but instead of using the
same matrix which is your your empirical
covariance matrix you use slightly
different matrices ok so I think from
here you can probably imagine imagine
how it works a few of the key steps you
need to show that the initial random
guess is not too bad it's pretty bad but
it's not too bad and then more or less
standard results tell you that the
empirical covariance in each block if
the blocks are big enough is going to be
good and then the spirit of efficient
representation here I've condensed about
a year of youngsters work into two blue
bullets so the all the work is to show
that it's it's not enough if I just tell
you that you're doing that you're doing
a power method with matrices that are
close to what you want that's not quite
enough because if I could design those
in some in some devilish way then
you don't need to converge in anything
the reason is that you start you start
so far away that it's so it's not enough
to just use sort of to use standard
results and say that my empirical
covariance is close to my population
covariance you need you need something
something more and because they because
the initial guess is going to be quite
bad it's not going to be very close to
your to your true signal the initial
error decay is not what you what you
typically see in power method but but
after if after a little while it becomes
linear so that that's the real reason
why we need a log P if we this log P
extra factor so if we start it out with
a good guess then then we wouldn't we
would not need that that's just if you
just choose a random vector you'll
you'll get something you'll see
something like that unfortunately yeah
if you could find something that's that
has an angle that's bounded away from 90
degrees independent of dimension then
you would of course do much better yeah
that's right that's right that's right
the it's really only the blue steps that
needed work everything else is pretty
much standard then the kind of technical
innovation was needed to tip because of
those two those two steps everything
else is just use kind of existing
existing results and again if you want k
principal components instead of one it's
it's straight forward to it to do that
so there's a number of extensions that
you can that you can get almost for free
one is that I mentioned that that Laura
and Ben and Rob I their their grouse
algorithm was actually designed not to
deal with noise but to deal with lots of
erasers but you can but you can also do
that as well in this in this setting
so suppose that you're getting noisy
noisy data points why but every
coordinate is erased with some
probability so the point is that it's
again this is standard you can you can
adjust by rescaling and by making sure
that your that you adjust the the
diagonal you can get an unbiased
estimator of the covariance matrix so
instead of using the covariance matrix
in every block to do the power method
you use your estimator of the covariance
matrix and it's an unbiased estimator
and we have a good understanding do do I
guess this isn't classical I think it's
fair to say of convergence rates and so
basically you just you do and note again
that you can form this you can form this
estimator again you can do that you can
multiply by this estimator without ever
actually forming the covariance matrix
oh so that's that's the that's the point
so all this requires is essentially more
samples by a factor of 1 over Q squared
which is which is exactly what you would
what you would expect and the first
problem I mentioned if you have a if you
have square root of P servers and they
each have square root of P data points
so the point the key is that if you if
you allow each one of these servers to
send one vector I don't know of a way
where they could each send a vector to a
centralized so one natural guess would
be each one of these guys does perform
singular value decomposition and then
sends me the top singular about singular
vector and then I take those square root
of P singular vectors and again I
perform the same thing so that won't
work you're just going to be getting
complete complete garbage in this case
so the key is that they should use their
budget by sending a by sending sample by
sending one vector to the next to the
next server and then you can mirror you
can essentially replicate the streaming
power method on the servers and it's a
all the data were stored in in one place
so the problem is that this is a this
forces the algorithm to be cereal and I
think it's an interesting to think about
if there's a way to take advantage of
the fact that it sits on square root of
P servers again I haven't thought about
this much just listening to talks and we
realize that this is sort of a that this
problem is in line with the flavor of
results that Santosh and others were
we're talking about so here are two
extensions three extensions that I don't
know how to do I think they're more
difficult I've been interested for the
last several years on on statistical
problems where you have arbitrary
corruptions you can have different
flavors of corruptions either coordinate
wise corruptions or possibly entire
samples are arbitrarily corrupted and I
have n others we have some some ideas on
how to do this when you have access to
all the data and you can you can revisit
data but I think it's an interesting
interesting to understand what the
limitations of streaming are and your
inability to store in this in this
setting where you have corrupted
corrupted data so extensions of grouse
that Lara and and various sets of
co-authors have worked on which he calls
graça tries to do some kind of some kind
of l1 minimization in order to deal with
coordinate wise corruptions I don't
think that that will work when you have
noise in the noisy and the noisy setting
although i'm not i'm not sure but i
suspect that without noise it works
quite well but I think with noise you'll
find methods it's a different it's a
different story and similarly with with
sample wise corruptions I think these
are too challenging problems it's also
interesting to think about how how
quickly if v were changing and you were
getting one sample from from a moving
spike what you what you really require
there to a
to track that so you can find out more
we have a the papers is posted and I'm
happy to hear comments now or later if
anyone has especially if anyone has any
ideas about the stochastic approximation
the stochastic gradient descent type
approaches Thanks
so yeah so the question was a about the
cast gradient descent on the sort of on
the convex if I'd version of yeah so so
that will that's not what we do that
will that will work in the sense that we
know that it will converge and you can
get rates for the convergence my comment
their son addy is some natty shrub row
someone who's worked on this but the so
the issue there is that your variable
now is this lifted variable and unless
you were guaranteed that you could
always maintain low rank in which case
maybe you could force a factorization if
that ever becomes a full rank or close
to full rank variable then you're
already using up p squared memory just
to store that
so there they do actually they do
something really similar they phrase it
all in terms of the multiplicative
experts framework but but if you if you
force so they're their weights are going
to be P squared themselves just to just
a store it
so you can do it by storing just two two
vectors that's a memory complexity
right
mm-hmm
so you'll have you have a 1 over epsilon
square dependence and you need about p
log p data points it's it's a little bit
worse because you need this because you
need to do so if you could have log P
passes over the data then you would get
the exact same exact same results but
because you're not allowed to
there's definitely hope as long as you
have the only thing that what what
what's magical about the Gaussian
assumption is just the cust the
concentration of of it of the noise
covariance I would just use I would just
look in the literature to see what the
largest singular value would be of the
noise of the noise empirical covariance
and then basically just plug that plug
that right right in and I think that
that would be fine yeah yeah
so uh so this is not a it's not an
algorithm that it's not like a gradient
it's not like a gradient algorithm which
gets closer and closer by by steps that
converge you're basically just doing
power you're just doing power method so
there's no there's no problem with
initial starting point or anything like
that so no is a short answer that that
there's no local aspect of it if you
were able to tell me that if you were
able to give me a good guess I wouldn't
need that extra factor of log P data to
do it but since i since i don't have a
good guess and I just have to draw
something at random I have to pay that I
have to pay that price
thanks